[Musique]
il est avec nous ce soir
sacha baron cohen novibat charrette en
découdre
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
il
je suis très très heureux de vous
accueillir dans l'émission vraiment
merci santé à tous on peut pas boire
d'alcool ici on est en france on pouvait
faire en angleterre il se peut pas
[Rires]
cocaïne la cocaïne ont fait 3 500 morts
ok mais on est en france je pensais que
d'accord enfin vous montrer comment
enlever les blessés en utilisant un
trombone basse est d'accord et est-ce
qu'on a du bon hockey
je crois au hockey sont pas le rosbif
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
passé on va passer pour des cons en
allemand mais j'y crois pas du tout et
que trombone rien on n'a pas les éclés
sait pas on les a pas de qui j'hérite
les faits quand je suis arrivé la veille
en libye et elle sont ils pensent
qu'elles sont dans sa loge
alors est ce que tu veux qu'on aille
ensemble chercher les clés dans la loge
alors on est dans la loge la noue alors
c'est qu'il ya les quais les quais ou
pas vous avez pas les clés les stresser
non non non pas les clés ou l'anomie ok
vous en faites pas c'est que ça sert
cette connerie on peut mettre j'ai
environ la semaine je commence à être
pas bien frais sur la n7 pas bien frais
allez on courait à vis de ma mère j'ai
la rage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêté
à aider avec tes la musique y voit
patron néo nantes a national voit pas
qu'on aura sera de folie tout ya un gars
qui est venu que j'aime
voilà il est venu sont finies les ont si
un gars et je croyais que c'était une
vanne au début si vous nous rejoignez
voilà yano pic est avec nous et il est
là il me met les menottes
il me dit va désormais avec du beurre et
un trombone et le gars a vraiment je
croyais que c'était une balle au début
je suis libre c'est un happening ces
sympathiques on quitterait le frère est
ce que tu crois qu'il a vraiment perdu
la trace
il a un trou dans sa poche le gard
[Applaudissements]
vous
mais jamais nous sommes dans la barre
à
c'est fou la ména frère il faut il faut
il me faut déjà bien ne t'en fais pas
attention là ce qui suit le serrurier
pour de vrai non mais sans dec qui vous
attaquez les chevriers témoin merci tu
veux
[Applaudissements]
oui
je suis pas l'homme violait pas mal ce
groupe src trophy les gars je n'aime pas
partager
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est là c'est la seule émission on
accueille aussi aux écoles invitées
normes en direct gens dire allez tout de
suite là qu'est le galway effet des
familles et tout c'est notre ratio est
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
midi en france avec une magnifique voix
lasse elle avait admis sortez moi de là
la lutte à main et carte mais ça fait
peur
vous allez rire mois sacré bout je passe
passe avant de couper la main
non ça marche pas quelle connerie c'est
la trouvaille de loi attendu ne dis pas
que c'est la clé soirée merci c'est la
curée non tu sais la queue et cyril
virez les tous ces autres qui vous la
donner là ils affaibliraient non fois
exprès ouah bobos
alors
lalonde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]